I remember when I was a kid everybody
wanted to see King Kong everyone but he
wanted to see Frankenstein people love
things that are bigger than life and
they didn't make that many until
recently when the producers discovered
that these superheroes are just the most
popular things ever with the public some
sometimes ask the question is there
superhero fatigue take this year we'll
see the amazing spider-man the second
one that'll be followed by the third one
in 2016 and a fourth one in 2018 do you
think at a certain point moviegoers get
spider-man fatigue look at something
like James Bond I don't know how long
that's been going on and it's still a
big event when a new James Bond movie
comes out I think it'll be the same
thing with these Marvel superheroes
let's compare spider-man which is
released by Sony and x-men which is
released by Fox and movie theaters to
the many films Marvel films that are
being distributed by Disney now the
latest one being the new Captain America
movie some of the numbers of the box
office would suggest that the Marvel
films under Disney are bringing in even
more box office bucks than with some of
the others if that's the case what does
that tell you it's like anything else if
you have a plethora of characters if you
have eight or ten characters some are
going to be a little more popular than
others but the amazing thing about these
movies every one of them seems to do
well some may be bigger blockbusters
than others but this seems to be at the
moment an insatiable demand for these
type of movies a lot of people are
already pointing to the next Avengers
potentially is having because of the
global box office the nature of where
these films can go now possibly being
the biggest film of all time would that
surprise you not at all
Warner Brothers obviously has the DC
family of characters doesn't seem like
they've generated as much at the box
office
in recent years do you have any thoughts
on that I wish my friend Bob Kane were
still with us he's the fellow who
created Batman Bob always used to tease
me about the fact that Batman was a big
deal on television and in movies and we
at Marvel had done nothing I wish he was
here now so I could return that teasing
a character should be somebody that the
reader or viewer really cares about and
maybe at Marvel we put a little more
effort into refining the characteristics
and the nature of our heroes maybe a
little more effort than they have on the
other side of the aisle you're not just
making cameos in these many Marvel
movies you have been very busy at POW
and you're betting for example on the
Chinese market you have a Chinese
superhero film the Annihilator what kind
of expectations do you have for how that
movie can do at the box office I'm
hoping that the Annihilator which Pao is
producing will be a worldwide movie it's
not just for China and we're trying to
get heroes that represent other nations
we're working on a Latino superhero we
have one called chakra which is doing
very well in India and the Annihilator
is gonna be a very big movie
it's a typical I think Stanley type of
superhero movie there is such a demand
for these bigger than life characters
that we feel we at PAL feel that we're
really doing the public a favor by
giving them what they want there's a lot
of new technology out there Facebook a
company you know but another company
called oculus which makes virtual
reality technology or that's their focus
area when you hear about the rise of
things like
Virtual Reality technology what does
that mean for the future of the comic
book industry
well the comic books as comic books may
not remain as big as they had been
because pretty soon you'll be able to
get those now you can get those comic
book stories on your computer screen and
many other places but if you come up
with the right project with the right
superhero and the right atmosphere and
the right power and with a good story it
almost doesn't matter whether it's on
the screen on a big screen a 3d screen a
computer screen or in a comic book or in
a novel a good story is a good story and
people have always wanted good stories
you're now 91 years old you're as busy
as ever you're coming up with new
characters you're a tweeting machine
you're on Twitter I think a lot of
people would like to know what is Stan
Lee eat for breakfast I have had the
same breakfast every morning for years I
have granola with milk with half a
banana with blueberries and a cup of
coffee preceded by a glass of orange
juice